[Music]
how are you I'm well I'm well I'm
sitting back there like sweatin and
churning cuz all these memories are
coming up and it's just like wow that's
a lot up in there right I'm actually
nervous too because it's like telling
the world especially the people who know
you well isn't it ironic that after all
these years there's a stigma underneath
that what is the stigma shame mm-hmm
some sort of shame
how long have been diagnosed I've been
living with HIV for nine months
last fall I started getting sick and I
never got better up until a friend of
mine pointed out that I was sick all the
time
I moved out on the 1st of December of
last year and then I got my results
four days after so it was a lot as soon
as I saw that it was reactive my entire
body almost shut down I could not say a
word for me I had slept with about I
think seven people at that time I was 23
I think it was at the time nobody knew
what caused it it was bathhouses and
poppers and I had never gotten near
either of those that's what they said
they thought it was my roommate said
well I think it's tested for that
disease and oh my cool you don't do
drugs we went to support him and we all
got tested together we all that tested
positive together and Tony's dead and
Jim is still alive I felt so alone even
next to somebody I salute Lee completely
alone
researchers know of 413 people who have
contracted the condition in the past
year one-third have died and not have
been cured death didn't scare news it
was living with this for a long time
that's more frightening than
then death today researchers here at the
National Centers for Disease Control
said they had found several cases where
people who had been sex partners both
had the condition the scientists say
this probably means they are dealing
with some new deadly sexually
transmitted disease it's fascinating to
hear your story because this the
reactions are almost the same
what was your knowledge of all of it I
knew that science has definitely
improved and it's become very advanced I
feared not necessarily for my life but
for getting in trouble with my family
but I also knew that I stood a chance I
was told more than once by specialists
saying that you are more than likely to
die from a car accident than with what
you have
[Music]
[Music]
if I'm dying from anything I'm dying
from the fact that not enough rich white
heterosexual men have gotten AIDS for
anybody to give it all the newspapers I
read tell me that IV drug users and
homosexual still accounts for the
overwhelming majority of cases and those
at risk AIDS is a tested who we are as a
people so we would make quilts for
anybody who died it filled the entire
mall that wouldn't Hillary and Bill
showed up there the first politicians to
ever show up in a gaucho and she was as
far away from me as that Wallace and
just they were there no fanfare they
came to respect and I Christmas sobbing
and I just thank you
it's like somebody acknowledged us for
the first time she showed up nobody else
did it's just because we were gay and
it's just so stupid
and when something like that happens you
realize my spirit is contingent upon the
belief in another person in me
now were they about it have you told
them I have told them last week how was
that I said before anything I want you
to know I am being taken care of I am
taking care of myself I will be okay I
told them that I was HIV positive my
mother broke down in tears
my father was clearly affected as well
but it seemed to me as if he was in
denial at that moment when I told my mom
I said okay so it's just so you know
I've had this for 10 years
and unfortunately I reached the place
where I have to go on medication and
it's an experiment they don't know
what's gonna happen to me I could die
for the medication and I figured I
should tell you now at this point
instead of something just happening you
finding out
how many pills are you taking luckily
just one oh my god that's awesome there
was a point when I was taking 18 oh my
god three times a day part of the
process to get where we are today is we
would just volunteer everyone donate
their bodies to science I did a
vaccination study one time anywhere I
got an injection at 6:30 in the morning
they drew my blood every 15 minutes for
the next three hours then at every half
hour all the way for 12 hours and I had
all of it on my arms they're gonna go to
my legs next and you just did it because
you had to you had to and you wanted to
[Music]
[Music]
what are you most afraid of to get
rejected by or say your own blood to be
thought of differently that there is a
possibility that in their minds you are
just an HIV positive person what were
you most afraid of it sounds odd I was
most afraid that I was never gonna be
able to ride horses again if you ever
run across a person who's long term
survivor and they look dead or tired or
depressed or they're bitter just know
they're a little bit tired we have it
good having your friends and families
die if it's dark compared to the now I
tell you if you ever decide to reach out
and continue to foster friendships with
people who are from my generation they'd
probably thrive on it
[Music]
hey guys do you know what's this panic
Heritage Month
nobody you got four more left email
content who's right here